bienvenue à la facture on vous le dit
souvent la rétrofacturation c'est un
droit et ce dans presque toutes les
provinces un outil conçu pour vous aider
face aux commerçants mais pour que ça
marche il faut un troisième joueur votre
institution financière or vous allez
voir qu'elle ne respecte pas toujours la
loi
[Musique]
si nous vivions dans le film Retour vers
le futur
nous pourrions faire marche arrière et
effacer nos erreurs bref s'arranger avec
le garde des vues heureusement dans le
monde de la consommation un retour dans
le temps est presque possible
on appelle ça la rétrofacturation et
comme vous allez le voir certaines
institutions bancaires ne respectent pas
la loi
j'adorais mon idée parce que c'était un
cadeau vraiment surprise
[Musique]
Noël 2019 Anne-Christine Bélanger achète
des billets de RTL expérience en ligne
pour les offrir à son conjoint
379 dollars pour 8 tours de piste
comme les consommateurs désabusés de
notre reportage Anne-Christine Bélanger
croyait que ses billets étaient perdus
jusqu'à ce qu'elle entendent ceci à la
facture je vous rappelle que si vous
achetez vos billets à distance avec une
carte de crédit tant que le service pour
lequel vous avez payé n'a pas été offert
vous pouvez toujours recourir à la
rétrosacturation donc c'est ce qui m'a
donné comme le coup de pouce
mentionne quand on fait un achat en
ligne ou par téléphone par carte de
crédit et que le commerçant ne livre pas
la marchandise on peut demander à
l'émetteur de notre carte de crédit de
nous rembourser l'institution financière
à l'obligation de créditer votre compte
si vous respectez les paramètres de la
rétrofacturation c'est la loi j'ai tout
de suite téléphoné à VISA Desjardins
pour demander comment fonctionner la
rétrofacturation
Anne-Christine Deschamps rapidement
selon la jante au service à la clientèle
de VISA Desjardins le délai pour faire
une demande de rétrofacturation serait
dépassé puis quand il m'avait demandé
donc c'est pour une dépense de quelle
date et là j'ai mentionné évidemment
décembre 2019 puis après le royaume il
dit beaucoup trop tard madame c'est pas
possible c'est ce qu'on vous a dit au
téléphone que c'est trop tard
c'est 90 jours c'est comme ça
Claude derbérubé est avocate est chargé
de cours à l'Université de Sherbrooke
c'est pas acceptant du tout c'est de la
n'existe pas dans la Loi sur la
protection du consommateur on ne peut
pas prévoir en hypolitique interne dans
des conventions quelconque des délais
différents qui prive consommateur de ses
droits
voici ce que vous devriez entendre au
sujet des véritables délais ce dictées
par la loi si vous souhaitez faire une
demande de rétro facturation comme
consommateur vous devez accorder un
délai de grâce de 30 jours au commerçant
pour honorer son engagement vous pouvez
ensuite annuler votre contrat en tout
temps tant que le service n'a pas été
reçu si au bout de deux semaines le
commerçant ne vous rembourse pas ou s'il
ne répond pas vous pouvez alors vous
tourner vers l'émetteur de votre carte
de crédit pour faire une demande de
rétrofacturation attention cette demande
doit se faire par écrit et vous avez
deux mois pour la faire oui clairement
c'est quelque chose dans la chaîne qui
fonctionne pas
Anne-Christine téléphone de nouveau à
VISA Desjardins cette fois devant notre
caméra comme vous allez le voir il
semble y avoir confusion entre
rétrofacturation et contestation oui
bonjour en fait j'appelle pour avoir de
l'information concernant la
rétrofacturation j'aimerais en fait
faire une demande concernant une une
dépense pour laquelle j'ai jamais pu
avoir le service
c'est quoi votre délai
je suis déçu parce que
mon appel en janvier était pas du tout
était pas du tout pareil non on n'a
jamais parlé d'un autre un autre délai
que j'aurais peut-être même pu régler ça
des janvier dernier avec le délai de 540
jours
Desjardins refusent notre demande
d'entrevue les par courriels
l'institution confirme l'existence de
délai de 90 jours et de 540 jours en
fonction des règles fixées par les
réseaux de paiement comme Visa ou
Mastercard mais attention Desjardins
évoquent ici des règles de contestation
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
rétrofacturation ce constat que des
élections financières doivent donner
leur juste doivent dire la vérité le
fait de dire en consommateur
malheureusement ça fait plus de 90 jours
plus de 540 jours que votre transaction
est effectuée
si le consommateur respectait la loi
éclinction financière vient ajouter un
délai qui n'existe pas dans la loi c'est
illégal mais ce n'est pas tout certaines
institutions bancaires comme étant ainsi
une double faute un commerçant qui donne
les informations qui sont fausses ou
trompeuses communs également d'autres
pratiques qui sont interdites par la loi
sur la protection du consommateur
pour voir si ce type de discours
erroné des institutions bancaires et
fréquent nous décidons de faire un test
avec trois autres consommateurs tous
avaient des billets pour participer à
différents événements de course à pied
constamment reporté depuis le début de
la covid
Marie-Josée Goudreau est cliente de Visa
TD ici aussi on lui répond qu'elle n'a
pas droit à la rétrofacturation
encourager en 90 jours de l'achat oui
mais la loi de la protection du
consommateur dit que vous devez
l'effectuer la rétrofacturation
que j'aimerais bien le faire pour vous
c'est juste on a des procédures aussi si
ça dépasse 90 jours on pourra pas
t'aider applique elle aussi ses règles
internes et fait fi de la loi sur la
rétrofacturation
Alexandre Plourde est avocat et analyste
chez option consommateur nous lui
soumettons nos enregistrements le délai
pour demander la rétrofacture dans la
loi sera protection du consommateur il
ne se calcule pas la partie de la date
de l'achat mais ce calcul à partir du
moment où le consommateur décide
d'annuler son achat
la banque Toronto Dominion refuse elle
aussi de nous accorder une entrevue mais
explique par courriel nous sommes
désolés que de nos clientes est reçu des
informations
erronées et nous prenons des mesures
pour nous assurer que nos équipes
disposent des renseignements nécessaires
en ce qui concerne la protection des
consommateurs soyez assurés que nous
suivons les lois en vigueur
Isabelle Riedel est cliente de visa
Banque Laurentienne son appel bandit
d'un service à l'autre
elle tombe enfin sur la bonne personne
et bingo elle reçoit la marche à suivre
vous devez leur écrire un courriel ou
vous dire que vous voulez qu'on
rembourser totalement vous laissez comme
ça deux semaines puis après deux
semaines s'il me répond pas je peux vous
rappeler
[Musique]
quelle note on donne Banque Laurentienne
remboursement je donnerai 10 sur 10 à la
banque au moins j'ai un plan je vais
voir qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui en est
je fais je poursuivre mais on verra dans
deux semaines ce que les gens vont dire
et voici notre dernier cas Pierre Luc
oui mais est avec la Banque Nationale
[Musique]
votre patience vous allez avoir votre
crédit de ce montant là sur votre projet
vous avez attendu combien de temps au
téléphone le présentement j'ai entendu
une heure et demie à peu près au
téléphone le temps c'est de l'argent
puis
[Musique]
alors la Banque Laurentienne a-t-elle
toujours 10 sur 10 et non parce qu'elle
n'a pas répondu à un ami dans les délais
nous avons relancé la banque qui lui a
promis de la rembourser et la TD a
finalement remboursé madame Goudreau
alors si vous croyez que votre
institution financière ne respecte pas
vos droits portez plainte à l'eau PC ou
adressez-vous aux petites créances